No.
What,
what women want are dangerous men who
are civilized and they want to help
civilize them.
Beauty and the beast.
So,
you know,
I'll tell you a funny story and only
engineers could have come up with this
because they are the only ones that have
the unparalleled blindness to social
convention that would allow them to
discover it.
So the Google engineers,
I like engineers by the way,
cause they're very straight forward.
The Google engineers wrote a book a
while back called a billion wicked
thoughts,
which was a study of Internet searches,
billions of them literally.
And they were looking a lot at
pornography use and well there's lots of
knowing about male pornography use
partly and it's easy to understand.
I mean,
males are,
you know,
pretty visually oriented and what
attracts them to pornography is fairly
straight forward.
Um,
you can tell that if you look at
graffiti and a men's washroom,
you know,
it's like two circles and a triangle and
the men are absolutely transfixed.
Bye.
[inaudible].
So
for women,
the story is more complex.
They use pornography too.
But it tends to be literary because
women tend to like words more than they
like visual stimuli.
And so the Google guys tried to track
down the archetipal structure of all,
they didn't use those words of female
pornography use.
And so some of you know,
how many of you know what a Harlequin
Romances.
Okay,
good.
So those are archetypal stories,
right?
That's the taming of the wild man.
Essentially by the,
by the desirable and virgin a woman.
And if you think women don't want that,
then you better bloody well come up with
an explanation for 50 shades of grey.
Right?
Which is the most,
the most rapid selling novel in human
history and,
and merged at exactly the same time that
all of this noise about the lack of the
absence of gender roles is,
is being produced.
You know,
on Mohs.
It's like perfect female fantasy.
It's exactly Arkan typically correct.
It's beauty and the beast.
So what they do go guys showed was the
structure of beauty and the beast,
although they didn't use that as a
reference that the female pornographic
fantasy was wild guy.
Um,
you know,
somewhat careless about the wants and
desires of others,
attractive to everyone.
Therefore,
High Status Tamed by the Magic of a
single woman and brought into a
relationship with her.
Okay,
so,
but here's the comical part.
This just made me laugh,
man.
It was like,
why were the five categories of most
desirable male entity used most broadly
and female pornography?
Oh,
it's so embarrassing.
Women,
you have to cover your head.
Well,
I say this because vampire,
we're wolf billionaire surgeon and
pirate.